during the riots there have been
real-time updates and cleanups are
organized on sites like Twitter and
Facebook the Prime Minister's also asked
for a review into whether social media
sites should be shut down during times
of unrest to stop looters contacting
each other let's talk about this a bit
I'm joined now by three people all
prominent on Twitter Conservative MP
Louise mensch former Labour Deputy Prime
Minister lord Prescott and Paul Lewis
who's been tweeting updates for the
Guardian from the scene of the riots
over the Parsee days thank you all for
joining us Paul Lewis if I could start
with you what about this idea the
government would shut down social
networking sites in times of trouble
well I mean I my personal view is that
we do need to remain cautious in times
of crisis it's often the case that
societies seek an answer and they seek
to do something about it but equally I
think it's testament to us if we can
hold strong we can avoid knee-jerk
reactions and we can remember that
social media is a new form of
communication it is with us to stay it's
not going anywhere
and it's really no surprise that anybody
doing any action whether it's criminal
or or in fact lawful would be using a
new form of communication to speak to
each other so I don't think that's a
surprise I genuinely do think it is a
surprise that the government have
announced this move and I'll tell you
why I mean if you think about the type
societies that have done this in the
recent past they are countries like
Egypt and there have been real
consequences for freedom of expression
in those places social media hasn't
which is to organize themselves forget
it's been used by journalists like
myself to communicate what was happening
in the riots when Louise mention and
Lord Prescott want to impede that let's
not forget that social media okay and
used to buy people to clean up after the
rights would they also want to impede
report you raise a lot of points there
can I turn to Louise Med sure we like
Egypt if we closed down Twitter when
things go bad no of course not that's
not what the Prime Minister is talking
about either we're saying that if the
police feel in a time of overwhelming
national crisis that they would need to
show I'm very briefly half an hour an
hour maximum it's something that we can
look at I mean there are lots of other
things we want to look at first Twitter
for example house up our top hashtags
being used it can suppress that we can
look at banning individual users from
Twitter and Facebook if we think they
are organizing riots this may require
more monitoring on the part of the
companies than presently exists shutting
treads down would be a last resort it
would only be very brief and very
temporary it's amazing to see people
getting their knickers in a twist about
this law Prescott well first of all it
was this true said twitting is for twits
and he's very asked out through it
anyway and it was something else that
was thrown in with everything else to
look as if he was acting on it look I
don't know where the louise has looked
in the technical fact whether you can
close it down but I don't accept the
argument Paul that in fact it's a force
for evil it's a force for good and
Louise if you've been reading all the
tweets of the oh you do you will see the
many people who depended on this way of
Twitter and Twitter to help them in
these crises more gain from it than
those who were disadvantaged by it and I
totally agree with Laura Prescott that
there is a force for good there's no
doubt about it I use it all the time
we saw the riot cleanup hashtag we saw
the riot Wombles hashtag we saw people
mobilizing on Twitter's your report says
for use of good but there was a certain
time during the riots as the prime
minister the House of Commons where
things were being organized on social
media
oh poor Louis's own report talked about
riot and M feels that with the Guardian
he said was organized in advance by use
of blackberry messenger so if we are
talking about very brief very limited
service interruptions that's one option
as I say it would be Louise mention
question she said there that she'd been
ports but she said previously that what
she advocated was temporary shutdown of
social media now social media is the way
journalists report now what she's
essentially saying is that she's
advocating something equivalent to a
media blackout at times of crisis at
times when people need to know what's
happening times and journalists like
myself he say utilize social media to
get the message out we're talking about
a brief interruption coverage when
Twitter goes down for maintenance the
whole world doesn't know its marbles I
think people are over egging but using
massively hear as I say this will be a
large tax we could stop it Orioles users
yes Louise you actually take judgments
as you did with Piers Morgan without
looking at the facts and can you tell me
can you do it selectively or does it
have to be done nationally and I don't
even agree with closing it down there
are millions of people who use this
including yourself as a means of using
it and the police do the same thing I
know you're in America at the moment
could you tilt
you've done a tweet saying you're gonna
buy a wedding dress after this debate
can I suggest you go to the New York
police their social media outfit for
monitoring and helping them in these
criminal cases the police use it
accordingly people using the security
they say that they're going to be
monitoring crimes on Twitter and
Facebook and I think that's a very good
idea
I heard from my local police force that
rumors spreads on Twitter caused
unnecessary fear-mongering lots of
pressure on the call center in
Northamptonshire there were fake reports
a rise in Wellingborough that didn't
happen of course Twitter wasn't a force
for good I love it I used all the time
it's been terrific during the riots
overall but there may be cases where
there's limited case for either shut
down or stopping hashtags for example
that you could do without shutting down
the whole network and I think saying
social medias Totem we can't touch it
with a barge pole it's just like saying
we should never shut down a road or a
railway station and we are only talking
about the briefest interruption of
service the fact that people are getting
in such a larger and such a froth about
it I think is ridiculous Paul Lewis Paul
Louis it sounds to me slightly as though
you know mint is saying here it's pretty
much the equivalent to say you know
during the the rural swing riots of 1830
it was being organized by pamphlets
let's somehow impede pamphlets that's
freedom of expression
she knows that Twitter has been used by
people like myself by others not just to
report what's going on but to dampen
down that very speculation that she was
talking police were using it journalists
were using it Sky News was using it
brilliantly itself and I think if we
were to impede that to lose that simply
as a knee-jerk reaction as though as a
reaction in a moment crisis that would
be hot-headed and that would be wrong it
would be something that the police it
would be something that the police would
be calling for and it would only be done
if the Metropolitan Police the lead
police was in a national emergency said
they wanted it done it wouldn't be done
on the whim of government and let's not
forget this is a 21st century equivalent
of shouting fire in a crowded theater
there's no threat reading over
expression by a very brief interruption
as I say we can look at shutting down
hashtag streams before we looked at
closing the network of parts the network
we can look at individual users you
don't want to go to the last resort
first but I think that police should
have the tools that they asked for and
it amazes me that North Prescott is
saying apparently but if the police
officer is tool they shouldn't have it
however briefly no I'm not saying that
the police sing it and if you go to New
York you'll see they're using it there
the police want it the community wants
it we want it the press need it this is
an important expression of freedom and
Louise you were the one who used the
freedom of Parliament actually to say
something about Morgan and then that to
apologize after why do you want to
censorship in this system unless the
police ask for it so the point is
completely moot isn't it we're not just
saying that shut down national emergency
if the police required it okay now can I
just start can I just enter another
thought here pause can I can I just ask
you having looked I'm sure you did at
the debate in the House of Commons about
the causes of the rioting do you feel
that by and large Westminster is looking
in the right places for the answers to
the problems well look I I want to say
this I think this is quite important
because I was one of the first reporters
to say that social media particularly
blackberry messenger was being used to
to break some of these riots but that
word orchestrate we should be careful
about I said it and I wrote it in the
loosest of terms because it has been
happening in loose terms such as have
been flying around destinations have
been announced targets have have been
described and sometimes people turn up
other people other times people don't
but we're not talking here about some
great you know feared monster
technological monster in itself caused
the riots the rioting has been done by
people they've been communicating as
people do in the modern age I think it
outs of what that's where it starts and
that's
little Prescott how do you think the
House of Commons debate went well it the
other day into the causes of this well I
think what mr. Cameron did was come up
with a whole load of issues of which he
said he makes changes now of course they
weren't already in the law but they
weren't used by the police and now that
in fact he's trying to make the police
look as if they didn't carry out the
actions and he had to G them up now he's
having to apologize
a typical camera maneuver it's the same
attitudes got about twitting as he's got
about the organization and riots it's
all about PR as Louise is an expert in
stimulates a debate but doesn't really
know what the facts are
Louise meant I know exactly what the
facts are and I think most people
perfectly will agree with the Prime
Minister when he came back and announced
that the numbers of police officer
should be raised from 6,000 to 16,000
and we saw those tactics being used
extremely effectively to police and
politicians job to hold the police to
account for the job that they do now if
the police say that in an absolute
urgency they would require a brief
interruption of service I don't think
it's anything for anybody to get
lathered up over and comparisons with
Egypt or so we're gonna have to leave it
at max I'm sorry we've gotta leave it
there he's been shot Prescott thank you
very much indeed Paul Lewis as well
thank you all three for joining us